hallo das klappt weiß nicht ich backe
sorry leute und bevor es jetzt hier los
geht mit der vorstellung meiner fünf top
westen minecraft texture pack möchte ich
noch mal ganz kurz sagen dass diese
playlist quasi ich jetzt angelegt haben
sie heißt jetzt top 5 in minecraft also
die besten dinge wo ich einfach in
verschiedenen kategorien letzte mal
waren es meine top 5 mods aus meiner
sicht aus was meine meinung da meinten
viele öl das und das ist doch viel
besser
das ist meine meinung dessen meine top
fünf besten mods in der letzten folge
gewesen weil viele haben mich gefragt ja
welche texte packs magst du denn gern
oder was ist denn ein lieblingskind oder
welche spielmodi spielst du am liebsten
oder halt beispielsweise aufpassen deine
lieblings mods und deswegen hab ich
gedacht ich stelle ich das einfach mal
vor was ich am coolsten finde minecraft
deswegen wenn es euch gefällt und ich
davon mehr machen will dann zeigt mir
bitte mit einem daumen hoch und wenn ihr
meinen wir wollen nicht wissen was für
die top fünf sachen sind die tour ganz
gut findest dann macht einfach einen
daumen nach unten das total legitim dass
es einfach ganz klar dass ihr eure
meinung sagen können
solange das alles auf einer normalen
ebene basiert und ihr nicht gleich tut
halt für um beleidigt in den kommentaren
weil das in letzter zeit ein paar leute
mal gemacht haben
ist damit alles in ordnung das heißt
wenn ihr mehr top 5 volt also als
nächstes jahr das am beispiel top fünf
spielmodi in minecraft nicht ganz cool
finde oder top 5 skins oder wenn ihr
andere noch dinge habe die ich auch noch
zu toppen soll was da am besten finde
könnte es mir einfach eine kommentare
schreiben und ich würd sagen wir fangen
jetzt direkt an mit dem fünften platz
und zwar ist das fünftbeste texture pack
was ich finden in minecraft das
autograph wir sehen dass hier schon
eingeblendet das ist nicht die
aktuellste version die ich gerade habe
aber das ist relativ egal ich starte bei
jedem tag speck dass ich euch vorstellen
bei jedem platz starte ich hier im menü
damit ihr seht wie die ganzen schriften
sind auch wie das ganze hier aufgebaut
das finde ich sehr coole vor allem das
menü ist das schönste was ich bisher
gesehen habe
und zwar wenn es einfach deswegen weil
das mit diesem hölzernen ist und diese
schrift auch selbst mut ist also was ihr
bei allen texmex mitkriegen werdet ist
dass ich muss mit tipp-ex mark also das
ist halt wirklich mal eine meinung jetzt
werden wahrscheinlich wenn ich das jetzt
wohl nicht gesagt hätte würden jetzt
wieder voll viele ankommen und zum einen
höhe die sind ja alle voll pixelig und
die sind ja gar nicht hochauflösend in
weil es gibt glaube ich ein eher 3d
kraft oder red kräftig speck was 1024 x
1024 ist also total hochauflösend aber
das finde ich nicht cool ich bin
minecraft ist nur cool wenn es pixi
gepäck sind und das sehen wir hier schon
bei o2 kraft das ist mein fünfter platz
also der schlechteste quasi von
allerdings vorstellen
es ist so ein bisschen rpg meter weiter
schon relativ tief gefallene fackel
viele meinen ich sollte es nicht so
alles zusammen schneiden sondern das
ganze so ein bisschen als wäre hier so
wirklich drinnen und nicht so viel glück
hat setzen deswegen mache ich das mal
ihr könnt mir wirklich wie gesagt
verbesserung in die kommentare schreiben
weil ich mich da voll auf euch
zurückziehe
ja also das ist so ein bisschen rpg
mäßigkeit mir nicht ein bisschen
mittelalterlich
wir sehen alles ist ein bisschen trüb
durch den shader ist das jetzt in der
ferne so ein bisschen lila wenn ich
jetzt an pflege seht ihr dass das ganze
halt doch sein sondern etwas dunklere
bundeswehr entwickelt sich das ganze
eher zu neuen frauen alles in der ferne
sieht so ein bisschen lila getönt aus
das liegt damals shader und ihr seht
schon beispielsweise ich finds am
poppelsdorfer man den stein und an den
bäumen sieht man es besonders gut
oder halt am gras ist das ganze mit
diesem dunkleren farben so ein bisschen
mittelalter mäßig gehalten ist und damit
könnte man zb wundervolle burgen bauen
finde ich und halt einfach burgen
schlösser stadtmauern irgendwelche alten
sachen ich weiß auch damals der server
von let's rock minecraft ließen sie
glaube ich der server
war richtig geil oder halt einfach
solche mittelalter server kann man hier
mit perfect bauen und das ist auf jeden
fall meinen fünfter platz den vierten
platz bildet das paper cut outs oder
weil der höchste berg athos paperc a tec
speck und zwar finde ich dieses menü
total blöd dass muss ich wirklich sagen
aber ich habe gesagt ich fange bei jedem
tag speck im menü an um auch das menü zu
zeigen
wir sehen hier das ganze ist ein
bisschen blöd auch wenn ich jetzt hier
in die welt rein gehe und hier
beispielsweise mal ins inventar finde
ich das ganze sieht nicht gut aus was
sich allerdings bei diesem text speck
unglaublich geil finde ist dass hier
ich finde diese steine und wenn man in
höhlen geht und vor allem dieser dieser
dirt finde ich sie zur geige aus mit
shader das sieht so schön aus und vor
allem auch das holz also wenn ich jetzt
hier beispiel mal dieser akazienholz
blätter holzbretter nehme oder jetzt
hier die fichten notwendig sind die
schönsten holzsorten dann sieht es
richtig cool aus und lädt schon das ist
ein ganz normal gepixelte special pack
das ist irgendwie 30 32 32 über 16 16
sogar nur ich kann es mir eigentlich 2 3
4 5 6 7 8 ist es ein 16 16 texture pack
und einfach mal kurz nach gezählt - und
ich finde das hier das ist halt einfach
der grund warum es nicht auf platz eins
ist es einfach weil diese gräser sieht
nicht so geil auf dieses carl dieses
diese erde mit dem gras finde ich auch
nicht so gut gepixelt zusammen und halt
vor allem wegen diesem gräsern das finde
ich echt nicht so cool und was ich auch
unglaublich uncool findet sind einfach
diese schwert ich sie sind einfach so
aus die sind einfach nahezu genauso aus
wie im normalen die sehen einfach fast
genauso aus wie im default speck und in
die volltexte die so kacke aus also
dieses text beck habe ich jetzt zb durch
tadel entdeckt da wird das video
wahrscheinlich gerade nicht sehen aber
schade finde ich hätte es schmeckt gut
konfiguriert der hat ja sex mit
reingepackt hallo münchen
der sex mit reingepackt mit den
schwertern und so finde ich sehr schön
ich würde die stacks pack trotzdem nicht
verwenden weil die einzigen schönen
blöcke finde ich es wirklich stein okay
diese riffelung darauf sind jetzt gerade
wegen der sonne weil die tat ein
bisschen wird steht aber das einzig
schöne hier finde ich quasi sind die
ganzen holz sachen dann die erde unter
stein
das finde ich ist ganz cool bei diesen
texture pack und sonst der rest
ich weiß nicht mit dem rest gar nicht
anfreunden die tiere et cetera sind
default mäßig gehalten und die schwerter
und werkzeuge sind auch nicht so geil
und rüstungen auch nicht ausrüstung habe
ich gar nicht zeigt die rüstungen sind
auch nicht so das einzig wahre
ich finde einfach holz diese sachen ihr
meisten vorkommen also holz erde und
steinen sind relativ cool und auch hier
das sieht einfach cool aus hier
irgendwie weil sie nicht gefällt mir und
das ist auf jeden fall mein vierter
platz kommen wir nun zu meinem dritten
platz und zwar ist das dandelion texture
pack was ihr wahrscheinlich alle durch
den lieben herrn bergmann kennengelernt
habt ich ebenfalls danke an die ich
berge es ist auf jeden fall richtig
richtig cool über team jetzt echt super
so dass entdeckt hast wir gehen einfach
in die welt des menüs finde ich ist ein
bisschen ähnlich gehalten biokraft also
wir sehen uns sehr so ein bisschen holz
dann nur noch so ein bisschen frecher
lang pigs tiger so ein bisschen ruhiger
deswegen finde ich das auch besser
deswegen steht das auf den dritten platz
und nicht das brot zugkraft steine und
erde für mich jetzt nicht so cool aber
ich finde das gesamtpaket stimmt also
ist es jetzt keinen block wirklich dabei
wo ich sagen würde das ist unfassbar
cool das inventar geht auch so aber es
passt halt wirklich alles zusammen
also mir gefällt alles so ein bisschen
muss ich sagen deswegen ist dieses auf
jeden fall auf platz drei besser
positioniert als irgendwas biokraft wo
mir nur dass und das richtig gut gefällt
oder bei paperc hat obwohl mir die erde
und so der stein richtig gut gefallen
hat aber der rest gar nicht da hier
gefällt mir alles ein bisschen und ich
finde es sind ein paar sachen angepasst
also zum beispiel diese hühner oder so
ein paar andere tiere ich glaube wir
hatten hier hinten auch noch irgendwo
hat dich nicht irgendwo noch kühe sind
schon tot
da sind noch scharfe der sehen wir auch
die sind so ein bisschen angepasst ein
bisschen pixel und das ganze sieht vor
allem finde ich mit shader und auch ohne
shader kulas also ich hab mir gesagt ich
teste alle sachen einfach mal mit shader
an weil ich eigentlich dauerhaft mit
shader spieler mit shader sehen die
ganzen sachen immer noch ein bisschen
cooler aus deswegen habe ich mir gesagt
ich teste das alles mal mit shader aber
ich finde besonders hier halt irgendwie
sowas so was wie das hier beschreibt es
quasi schon direkt zu dieser kleine
platz hier unter dem baum im schatten
und so lässig und unfassbar schön aus
mit dem bandoneon texture pack und sowas
kann man einfach perfekt mit diesem
dandelion texture pack machen finde ich
irgendwie so bäume etc
das sieht alles richtig cool aus damit
und ich würde einfach sagen das ist mein
dritter platz ist das dann delhi und
action pack und ihr könnt mir übrigens
mal europa sind etwa ihr könnt mir
außerdem mal wenn ihr jetzt mein jahr
das sind das täglich aber viel cooler
dann schreibt mir das einfach meine
kommentare der euro erteilt auflistung
wie das ganze machen würde
und ja ich finde einfach so bäume et
cetera sieht unfassbar cool aus mit dem
dann delhi and expect und es passt
einfach alles zusammen kommen wir nun zu
dem zweiten platz und zwar ist der
zweite platz das good morning kraft
texture pack übrigens findet ihr alle
download-links selbstverständlich auch
in der beschreibung damit die selber
testen könnt es ist wieder hölzern
gehalten und ich fand es bei leon echt
besser das muss ich wirklich sagen
allerdings bin ich guten morning kraft
erinnert mich doch sehr stark an an
denen ich finde es allerdings wirklich
cooler
ich weiß nicht ist es wie gesagt viele
sagen jetzt eventuell wieder ölig von
paper karton aller coolsten ich finde
dass sie ganz cool vor allem weil die
mobs auch noch anders komplett anders
gemacht wurden beispielsweise die enden
diese hühner sehen jetzt aus enden
beispielsweise das ist ein ganz cooler
gag die ärzte sehen cool aus die
werkzeuge finde ich auch die hamas also
die sind so ein bisschen möchtest
außerdem weg die sind wirklich dass das
passt wirklich wieder einen dämon alles
zusammen aber ich find s pass besser
ich finde diese biome kommen viel besser
zur geltung gesehen hier wirklich dieses
landesverband oder hydra ich bin mir
nicht sicher tut mir leid denn mit
diesem baum hier finde ich sieht
unterscheidet sich extrem kreis dadurch
dieses david so richtig rot ist es sieht
man hier alles alles rot und hier ist
also alles grüner sitzen sind echt
klasse kontraste die wir bei dundee ja
nicht hatten und ich weiß nicht als ich
bin es immer so ein bisschen zu einer
anderen stelle geflogen und ich finde es
passt einfach alles zusammen diesen
pixeln und alles und ich mag einfach zu
übels pixi gesagt und das ist halt
wieder ein 16 16 tech speck und es passt
einfach und es sieht einfach mega cool
aus auch unter wasser
ich weiß nicht gut morning kraft könnte
ich mir nicht vorstellen also ich weiß
jetzt nicht dem neulich hab das noch
nicht ohne schilderte gespielt so jetzt
muss die welt natürlich ganz kurz
aufbauen wir befinden uns noch nicht in
der 1.8 das welt aufbauen ganz schnell
geht sondern immer noch in der 110 wegen
dem shader also ich finde sogar es geht
ohne shader relativ gut ich finde sogar
sieht ohne schneider ganz cool aus wir
können ja auch ohne shader
läuft das ganze auch natürlich ein
bisschen besser aber ich finde es sogar
ohne scheider ganz cool aus und ich kann
mir sogar vorstellen damit in zukunft
das ein oder andere video zu training
machen natürlich wieder den shader an
hier damit ihr das ganze wieder
vergleichen könnt also es sieht schon
sehr cool aus übrigens habe ich keine
face cam dabei weil viele meinten die
fans kennen bei sowas derzeit keine
emotionen da erzählen oder muss nicht
unbedingt ein face kam rein da stört
auch finde ich nur wenn man etwas zeigen
möchte dieser kleine balken da oben
links
weil sie nicht finde ich ist sehr sehr
cool ist action pack gefällt mir sehr
gut
good morning post schreibt mal wie es
euch gefällt download link ist in der
beschreibung
ich finde einfach weil es sich bei good
morning kraft passt einfach alles
zusammen das ist also nicht an de león
viel besser finde ich ist meine meinung
habe ich jetzt höre ich oft genug gesagt
hallo scharf und jetzt kommen wir zum
platz nummer eins in der wahrscheinlich
schon kennen wer hätte es gedacht platz
nummer eins ist zwecks zwecks ich habe
schon mal so ein video gemacht zu meinen
top 5 texture pack savvas wächst glaube
ich auch in den top-5 dabei ich glaube
sogar auf platz eins ich mir sicher
allerdings ist zwecks für mich wirklich
mal noch unangefochtene nummer eins good
morning kraft kommt da schon nach an ich
habe immer noch die self die welt kennt
auch bei langsamer menschen die mal
wieder in die welt des menu wir kennen
alles ich glaube ich muss zwecks nicht
beschreiben
zwecks ist einfach so ein text pack für
sich ist das einzige nichts mit expect
was ich mag und auch nicht apple sondern
dieses comic mäßig payback hat auch die
tat aus paperc hat autos aus den comic
mäßig gehalten habe ich den sex läuft
bei mir auch am besten ist ein 32 mal 32
sec also im gegensatz zu platz 4 3 und 2
diesmal nicht 16 16 es gibt zwecks auch
ein 16 16 hallodri pap aber ich finde
einfach dass waxing hochauflösenden
sachen sieht blöd aus ich mag es also in
wie gesagt ich mag's pixelig bei dem
tech speck könnte man sich mein okay
wenn man sich jetzt eventuell nicht so
bissig macht dann ist es eigentlich auch
ganz cool
also wenn man das ganze in die sich in
64 64 geht sogar noch über 128 128 oder
256 256 unterlegt dann ist
geschmackssache ich finde allerdings
dass sex und solche anderen tags einfach
in pigs liegen varianten also wenn man
das irgendwie in 32 mal 32 16 16 ist
schon fix ich finde ich halo ist klar
weil sie nicht ich backe sorry ich
find's einfach ich finds wächst sonntag
schipek für sich ich meine es ist so ich
weiß nicht die haben auch jetzt das ist
auch das professionellste tech speck was
ich kenne die haben das paar für alle
möglichen mord packs gemacht wir haben
eigene website
die verdienen damit unfassbares geld
durch die werbung und so weiter die
millionen von download links und ich
meine die doch einfach cool aus diese
ganzen comic blöcke und auch wenn ich
jetzt diese spitzhacke beispielsweise
eine andere oder diese blöcke die sieht
halt alles ein bisschen comic mäßig aus
gefällt mir unfassbar gut gucken bei
migranten bisschen gefällt mir richtig
gut ich mag's wächst einfach unglaublich
gerne ich lieg jemals ein stückchen und
damit ihr hier noch ein bisschen von der
wanne seht da hinten ok viele leute
wollen wahrscheinlich wieder
ich bin gut viele leute wollen
wahrscheinlich wieder anzieht haben das
heißt da ist der sieht 18 ganz selber im
ablesen auf pause klicken es ist sehr
sehr cool und zwecks ist halt einfach
wirklich muss man sagen muss man nicht
viel zu beschreiben jeder von euch
kennen zwecks zwecks ist ein ding für
sich das ist einfach alter was sticht
heraus
sie muss wissen das ist nicht so was mit
krassen bergen gemacht eigentlich das
ist echt einfach geil aussieht finde ich
ich weiß nicht ich finde jeden zieht
geil ich weiß nicht ich mag dieses spiel
ich mag die texture pack sich
vorgestellt habe ich finde dafür kann es
eigentlich am besten abschluss geben als
dieses coole bild hier einfach mal so zu
machen wenn es euch gefallen hat die
type ex werden euch die serie gefällt
glaube ich sag's viel zu oft dass ihren
daumen hoch geben sollte ich glaub ihr
wisst ja immer wenn es euch gefällt dann
zeigt es mir einfach dadurch wenn es
euch nicht gefällt dann halten daumen
runter akzeptiere ich natürlich
ich sage einfach dass man meine top 5
texture pack wenn ihr andere top 5 text
dann schreibt mir auf jeden fall und
eine beschreibung es interessiert mich
unglaublich weil ich selber noch auf der
suche nach dem komplett perfekten
texture pack also gut moni kräften kommt
schon daran aber so eine mischung aus
kraft und sex irgendwie somit den
spitzhacken und so von sex mit den
werkzeugen und sonst alles andere von
morning kraft und so das war richtig
geil aber ich bin einfach viel zu voll
um sowas zu machen
ich war einfach bis irgendwie so ein
perfektes tech speck für mich raus kommt
oder so und ich weiß nicht also den
zieht habt ihr meine rangliste steht
auch noch mal in der beschreibung unten
ihr könnt auf die download links findet
ihr unten und ich hoffe euch hat es
gefallen
wir sehen uns dann eventuell weiteren
topf im video kommt drauf an wie ihr
euch das so gefällt wo ich dann
eventuell meine high tech potsdam sogar
noch mehr auf eventuelle wo ich dann
meine top fünf games vorstelle top 5
spieler ist es viel zu spät
gute nacht also es ist gerade zwei über
nacht